oh looks like someone is having fun over
there tomorrow is mexican independence
day and jc fernandez is getting the
party started early yeah he is live at
his song santina at the shops inside
mandalay bay with some great ways to
celebrate hey jc
hey rocky mercedes we are having a blast
here it's the rock and roll mariachi ben
they're gonna go oh
i can put this on just like this yes
just like this
we're in business now will you please
play something for us right now
oh this is perfect
you're at who songs celebrating mexican
independence day the rock and roll
mariachi band
and i want you guys to meet someone very
special this is amy amy thank you for
joining us how do i look with myself it
looks good amazing
this is the theme definitely
what kind of margaritas do you have here
for us so right now we have a couple of
original margaritas made with the jose
cuervo and then right in the middle we
have a specialty jalapeno pineapple
margarita made with dulce vita really
good spicy sweet it looks delicious and
now i know you know the food here at hu
songs tell me more about the dishes that
you guys made for us so we have two
dishes right now we have the siete mares
which is the seventh uh ocean soup and
then we have the torta over here
in the soup it's gonna be mussels clams
white fish
we've got shrimp in there some onion and
cilantro and a guajillo broth and corn
tortillas on the side uh-huh super
delicious that's my favorite we gotta
give them then we have a torta over here
it's gonna be a grilled torta bread with
lettuce chipotle pickled habanero pep
pickled habanero onions yes pickled
jalapenos it's loaded in there it loaded
in there and then you get your choice of
carnitas barbecue or chicken perfect
it's so good delicious rock and roll
mariachi man uh they can play anything
how about can you guys give us some hip
hop
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
watch this how about how about brown eye
girl brown eye girl
[Music]
can we just go ahead and meet jc over
there
make sure you have the margaritas for
use
[Music]
that's impressive
every night rocking all my reaction man
guys it's amazing we gotta we gotta tell
them to learn way too sexy now too
all right thank you so much jc we will
check back in with you during the 4pm
newscast and